Well election season is upon us again. We've all already endured the news of the first Iowa straw poll. Ahead of us, 14 months of pondering the choice of presidential candidates who seem to excite nobody who you ever meet. And it feels like, once again, all of us are left in a position where we want to feel inspired, we want to believe in something, and nobody is showing up to do the job.
选举季又到了。我们已经熬过了爱荷华州首场民意调查的新闻。接下来还有14个月，我们要去思索那些似乎无法让任何你所遇见的人感到兴奋的总统候选人。感觉好像我们再次陷入了这样的境地：我们渴望受到鼓舞，我们渴望去相信什么，但却没有人能胜任这项工作。
And I find myself thinking about a candidate I met during the last presidential election. This wasn't anybody who made it big. His name was Chuck Wojslaw. He was a retired professor of electronics engineering running for office as a Republican in a mostly Democratic district of East San Jose.
我不禁想起我在上次总统大选中遇到的一位候选人。他并非大人物。他的名字叫查克·沃斯劳（Chuck Wojslaw）。他是一位退休的电子工程教授，在圣何塞东区的一个民主党占优势的选区以共和党人身份参选。
I met him at the Republican National Convention in San Diego, standing in the afternoon sun, wearing a red, white, and blue bicentennial tie. He'd never run for office before this. And talking to him, you could tell. I mean, he was so much more emotionally present than any normal political candidate you meet. He looked you in the eye. When you asked him a question, he actually answered it. And he had none of that robotic, not quite human, pod people affect that so many candidates end up having.
我在圣地亚哥的共和党全国代表大会上见到了他，他站在午后的阳光下，系着一条红白蓝三色的二百周年纪念领带。在这之前他从未竞选过公职。和他交谈时，你能感觉得到。我是说，他比你平常遇到的任何政治候选人都要真诚得多。他直视你的眼睛。当你问他问题时，他会认真回答。他身上完全没有那种许多候选人最终都会表现出的机器人般、不太像人类的异类气质。
I retired a tenured professorship to run for office. So I could have been secure in academia as a tenured professor.
我辞去了终身教职来竞选公职。我本来可以在学术界稳稳当当地做一名终身教授的。
Then why are you doing this?
那你为什么要这么做？
I love my country. I come from a really humble background. And my country, it has given me opportunity that all I had to do was take advantage of it. I'm the son of a coal miner.
我热爱我的国家。我出身寒微。而我的祖国，它给了我机会，我所要做的就是把握住它。我是矿工的儿子。
Are you somebody who's always wanted to run for office? You've always toyed with it in the back of your mind?
你是一直都想竞选公职的人吗？你心里是否一直有这个想法？
No.
不。
When did the idea come into your head?
这个念头是什么时候冒出来的？
Well, I had a family meeting. My daughter and a son, they're grown, college educated, off on their own. My wife and I got together and to my kids I says, it looks like I might want to take an early retirement. And so my daughter says, why don't you run for office? And I says, you got to be kidding. And I says, do you know what is involved with running for office? The mudslinging, and the long hours, and whatever.
嗯，我们开了个家庭会议。我的女儿和儿子都长大了，受过高等教育，独立生活了。我和妻子聚在一起，我跟孩子们说，看来我想提前退休了。我女儿就说，那你为什么不竞选公职呢？我说，你一定是在开玩笑。我说，你知道竞选公职意味着什么吗？抹黑、漫长的工作时间，诸如此类。
Then, all of a sudden, my daughter came up to me, and this is what turned my mind, she says, this is our country. We love it. If not you, who then? If not you, who then?
然后，突然间，我女儿走到我面前，正是这句话改变了我的想法，她说，这是我们的国家。我们热爱它。如果不是你，那会是谁呢？如果不是你，那会是谁呢？
And that's when you decided?
然后你就决定了？
Yeah.
是的。
He was spending $60,000 of his own retirement money to do this. And like a lot of people I met at the Republican Convention, what was most striking about Chuck Wojslaw was his idealism. He seemed completely sincere about what he was doing. This is the puzzle of the American political system. It's filled with lots of profoundly idealistic people working at all levels. And yet, it does not seem to produce idealistic candidates. I mean, what's the most inspiring thing you've ever heard Al Gore say, or George Bush junior, or Elizabeth Dole?
他自掏腰包花了6万美元退休金来做这件事。就像我在共和党大会上遇到的许多人一样，查克·沃斯劳最引人注目的是他的理想主义。他对自己所做的事情看起来极其真诚。这就是美国政治体系的谜题。它充满了在各级岗位上工作的、非常有理想主义的人。然而，它似乎并没有产出理想主义的候选人。我的意思是，你听过阿尔·戈尔、乔治·布什二世或伊丽莎白·多尔说过最鼓舞人心的话是什么？
Well, today on our radio program, as we head into another election season, to keep us all from feeling dispirited by the staged media events, the negative ads, the issues that have all been pretested in focus groups, we bring you stories of political idealists, stories to make us all feel some small sense of hope about politics in America. All of these stories taken from election coverage we did four years ago, here on This American Life .
今天在我们的广播节目中，随着我们进入又一个选举季，为了让我们不被那些舞台化的媒体事件、负面广告以及在焦点小组中预先测试过的议题所挫伤，我们为你带来政治理想主义者的故事，这些故事让我们对美国的政治感到一丝微小的希望。所有这些故事都选自四年前我们在这档《美国生活》（This American Life）节目中做的选举报道。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, I'm Ira Glass. Act one of our show today, Upside Down World. We have a campaign diary from Michael Lewis from four years ago about a politician you'll be hearing a lot about in the next few weeks and months. And the story of a moment when the opposite of normal politics became normal politics.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天节目的第一幕，“颠倒的世界”。我们有一篇迈克尔·刘易斯（Michael Lewis）四年前写的竞选日记，关于一位你在未来几周和几个月里会经常听到的政治家。以及关于一个瞬间的故事，那是正常的政治反面变成了正常政治的时刻。
Act Two, Kiss And Tell. A Walter Mondale voting, gay rights supporting, unrepentant liberal signs up as a Republican Party member and ends up a party functionary, a delegate to the state Republican convention, where he wreaks havoc.
第二幕，“亲吻与讲述”。一位支持沃尔特·蒙代尔（Walter Mondale）投票、支持同性恋权利、不悔改的自由派人士，注册成为了共和党成员，最终成为了一名党工、州共和党代表大会的代表，他在那里大闹了一场。
Act Three, Pete and Repeat. How California Governor Pete Wilson's anti-immigrant policies found some supporters among immigrants themselves. We hear an explanation of the profoundly idealistic notion of self-deportation.
第三幕，“彼得与重复”。加州州长彼得·威尔逊（Pete Wilson）的反移民政策是如何在移民中找到一些支持者的。我们听到了对“自我遣返”这一深刻理想主义概念的解释。
Act Four, Throwing Money at the Problem. You may recall a bestselling book from a few years ago called, There Are No Children Here , about two boys growing up in Chicago's Henry Horner public housing projects. Well those projects where across the street from the site of the 1996 Democratic Convention here in Chicago. And when the convention came to town, money poured in for a makeover of the neighborhood. One of the kids from the book, now grown up, gave us a tour showing us what got fixed up, and how the real improvements in the neighborhood all happened beneath the normal political radar. Stay with us.
第四幕，“用钱砸向问题”。你可能还记得几年前那本畅销书《这里没有孩子》（There Are No Children Here），讲述的是在芝加哥亨利·霍纳（Henry Horner）公共住房项目中长大的两个男孩的故事。那些项目就在芝加哥1996年民主党大会会场对面。当大会召开时，资金涌入以对社区进行翻新。书中的一个孩子，现在已经长大成人，带领我们参观了修复的地方，并展示了社区中真正的改善是如何在普通政治雷达之下发生的。请留在我们身边。
Act One, Upside Down World. We begin our program with this story of national politics as it is almost never practiced. To Michael Lewis, his campaign diaries from the last presidential race, were some of the most evocative and original reporting anybody did. His stories were novelistic, often very funny. This next story, which was first published in the New Republic magazine put Arizona Senator John McCain on the map for a lot of people in a way that he had never been before. It coincided with and it boosted a rise to national notoriety for McCain, who of course has now become a Republican presidential candidate himself. Here's Michael's dispatch.
第一幕，“颠倒的世界”。我们以这个关于国家政治的报道开始我们的节目，这种政治几乎从未被实践过。对迈克尔·刘易斯来说，他上一场总统竞选的日记是他所做过的最具感染力和原创性的报道之一。他的故事像小说一样，而且通常非常有趣。接下来的这个故事最初发表在《新共和》（New Republic）杂志上，它让亚利桑那州参议员约翰·麦凯恩（John McCain）在很多人心中建立起了以前从未有过的形象。这与麦凯恩声名鹊起的全国性影响相吻合，并推动了他的知名度，他现在当然已经成为了一名共和党总统候选人。以下是迈克尔的报道。
April the 19th, I leave my hotel earlier than I need to and walk down from the Washington Monument to the Vietnam Veterans Memorial. Even at 7:30 in the morning, the mall is nearly deserted, the Lincoln Memorial empty. The Vietnam Veterans Memorial, on the other hand, is teeming with people who appear to have up for hours, walking slowly along the length of the black marble slab bearing the names of the dead.
4月19日，我比原定时间更早离开酒店，从华盛顿纪念碑走向越南退伍军人纪念碑。即使是在清晨7点30分，购物中心也几乎空无一人，林肯纪念堂空荡荡的。另一方面，越南退伍军人纪念碑却挤满了人，他们似乎已经醒了几个小时，正沿着刻有死者名字的黑色大理石板缓慢行走。
For the next 20 minutes, I sit on a bench dodging bird droppings and waiting for Senator John McCain, who has agreed to meet me here. In my attempts to spot him at a distance, I can't help but notice how differently ordinary people behave from politicians. Maybe 50 likely candidates pass through my line of vision, and not one of them could pass for a US senator at 100 paces. They comb their hair in public, scratch themselves, hold hands.
接下来的20分钟，我坐在长椅上躲避鸟粪，等待约翰·麦凯恩参议员，他答应在这里见我。在试图从远处发现他时，我不禁注意到普通人的行为与政客有多么不同。大约有50个潜在的候选人进入了我的视线，没有一个能在百步之外被误认为是美国参议员。他们在公共场合梳头、抓痒、牵手。
At 8:00 on the button, McCain appears at my side, looking very senatorial except for a pair of outrageously wide, black aviator sunglasses with some undignified name, hobby, hippo stenciled on the earpiece. McCain is the Dole surrogate most in demand as a speaker around the country, and it's not hard to see why.
8点整，麦凯恩出现在我身边，看起来非常有参议员风范，除了一副极其宽大、黑色的飞行员太阳镜，镜架上还印着一个不怎么高雅的名字：hobby, hippo。麦凯恩是全国范围内多尔（Dole）最抢手的代理演讲人，原因显而易见。
What matters most to the people who wish to see McCain speak for Dole is the formative experience that the two senators ostensible share. Both nearly died in a war. Both endured indescribable pain and suffering. Dole's ordeal is at the center of his national campaign. To some extent, it is his campaign.
对于那些希望看到麦凯恩为多尔演讲的人来说，最重要的是两位参议员表面上共同拥有的成长经历。两人都曾在战争中差点丧命。两人都忍受了难以言表的痛苦和磨难。多尔的磨难是他全国竞选的核心。在某种程度上，这就是他的竞选本身。
McCain's trials are less known. On October 26, 1967, when he ejected out of his navy jet and into a North Vietnamese mob, McCain suffered two broken arms, a shattered knee and shoulder, and bayonet wounds in his ankle and groin.
麦凯恩的考验则鲜为人知。1967年10月26日，当他从海军喷气式飞机弹射出并落入北越暴民中时，麦凯恩双臂骨折，膝盖和肩膀粉碎，脚踝和腹股沟处有刺刀伤。
Robert Timberg's gripping book, The Nightingale's Song , depicts McCain, two months later, in his first prison cell. McCain weighed less than 100 pounds. His hair, flecked with gray since high school, was nearly snow white. Clots of food clung to his face, neck, hair, and beard. His cheeks were sunken, his neck chicken like, his legs atrophied.
罗伯特·廷伯格（Robert Timberg）引人入胜的书《夜莺之歌》（The Nightingale's Song）描述了两个月后麦凯恩在第一个牢房里的样子。麦凯恩体重不到100磅。他的头发自高中起就夹杂着灰色，现在几乎全白了。食物结块粘在他的脸上、脖子上、头发和胡须上。他的脸颊凹陷，脖子像鸡脖子，双腿萎缩。
McCain survived in captivity without medical treatment for the next five years, enduring torture so exquisite that even to read about it causes sweat to pop out on your brow. His captors would hang him by his broken arms from dangling ropes for hours on end, for instance.
麦凯恩在随后的五年里在没有医疗救助的情况下在囚禁中幸存下来，忍受着极其残酷的折磨，哪怕只是读到这些都会让人额头冒汗。例如，他的俘虏会把他挂在悬垂的绳子上，用他骨折的双臂支撑身体，一挂就是几个小时。
But the astonishing part of McCain's experience was its voluntary aspect. McCain is the third generation of a distinguished military family. His father was an admiral during the Vietnam War. The North Vietnamese hoped that this famous prisoner of war would violate US military policy, which dictated that prisoners be returned in the order they arrived. If he accepted their offer of freedom, McCain would testify to the demoralization of the American troops. For five and a half years, his captors tried torture him into going home. For five and a half years, he refused to go.
但麦凯恩经历中最令人震惊的部分是其自愿的成分。麦凯恩是杰出军人世家的第三代。他的父亲在越南战争期间是一名海军上将。北越人希望这位著名的战俘能违反美国军事政策，该政策规定战俘必须按抵达顺序遣返。如果他接受了自由的提议，麦凯恩将证明美军的士气低落。五年半的时间里，他的俘虏试图通过折磨让他回家。五年半的时间里，他拒绝离开。
We walk alongside the black granite slab against the oncoming traffic, then back again. The Park Service says that the memorial has become the second most frequently visited site in Washington, after the Capitol. McCain admits that at first he found it depressing and even faintly antagonistic.
我们沿着黑色花岗岩石板逆着人流行走，然后折返。国家公园管理局表示，该纪念碑已成为华盛顿访问量第二大的景点，仅次于国会大厦。麦凯恩承认，起初他觉得这里令人沮丧，甚至有些反感。
But one day, he was passing through on his own-- he visits often by himself-- and discovered a couple of veterans running their hands across the inscribed names. Clearly the two men had never met before, but they had fallen into conversation, swapped war stories, and in a few minutes we're clutching each other and weeping. If that kind of healing goes on, says McCain, well, then it's a good thing.
但有一天，他独自路过——他经常独自来访——发现一对老兵正在抚摸刻着的名字。显然这两个人以前从未见过面，但他们攀谈起来，交流了战争故事，几分钟内便拥抱在一起泪流满面。麦凯恩说，如果这种治愈能够发生，那么这倒是一件好事。
Someone once said that an explanation is where the mind comes to rest. There's a feeling about McCain, one that seems lacking in Dole, that he has somehow explained his own experience to himself. He has assimilated his trauma differently than the candidate he's behind.
有人曾说，解释是思维归于平静的地方。关于麦凯恩有一种感觉，这在多尔身上似乎缺乏，即他以某种方式向自己解释了自己的经历。他比他支持的候选人以不同的方式消化了自己的创伤。
He says, this is the McCain theory, and I think it's valid. I was an adult when I was shot down, 31 years old. I'd had a whole life. He was 19. What were you like when you were 19? I believe that everything Bob Dole has done since the war was dictated by that experience.
他说，这是麦凯恩理论，而且我认为它是成立的。我被击落时是成年人，31岁。我已经度过了完整的人生。他当时只有19岁。你在19岁时是什么样子的？我相信鲍勃·多尔战后所做的一切都是由那段经历所决定的。
The Vietnam veteran has achieved a kind of equanimity that is supposed to be reserved only for veterans of good wars. When Clinton arrived at the White House, for instance, McCain sent him a note saying that any time the President wished to walk down to the Vietnam's Veteran Memorial, the Senator from Arizona would be glad to walk alongside him. Clinton sent back a nice note.
这位越战老兵实现了一种平衡，这种平衡通常被认为只属于正义战争的老兵。例如，当克林顿入主白宫时，麦凯恩给他写了一张纸条，说任何时候总统想去越南退伍军人纪念碑散步，这位亚利桑那州的参议员都乐意陪同。克林顿回了一张友好的纸条。
Recalling this exchange causes McCain to break his rhythm. We were walking back towards the bench, and McCain is limping slightly, like a high school football star. He's remembering something else.
回想起这次交流让麦凯恩打断了他的节奏。我们正走回长椅，麦凯恩有点跛，像个高中橄榄球明星。他想起了别的事情。
I don't know if you want to write about this, he begins. Back in the mid-'80s, a guy who protested the war came into my office. He said his name was David Ifshin. In December 1970, David Ifshin had led a group of American students to Hanoi, where he delivered an anti-war radio address to American soldiers engaged in attacks on North Vietnam.
我不知道你是否想写这个，他开始说。80年代中期，一个抗议过战争的人来到我的办公室。他说他叫大卫·伊夫辛（David Ifshin）。1970年12月，大卫·伊夫辛带领一群美国学生去了河内，在那里发表了针对攻击北越的美军士兵的反战广播演说。
Like other anti-American propaganda, this program was piped into McCain's prison cell from 6:00 in the morning until 9:00 at night. But McCain, who can generate anger in a heartbeat, shows not the faintest trace of resentment. He explains, Ifshin stood in my office and he says, I came here to tell you, I made a mistake. I was wrong. And I'm sorry.
和其他反美宣传一样，这个节目从早上6点到晚上9点在麦凯恩的牢房里播放。但麦凯恩，那个可以在一瞬间产生愤怒的人，却表现出丝毫没有怨恨。他解释说，伊夫辛站在我的办公室里说，我来这里是为了告诉你，我犯了一个错误。我错了。我很抱歉。
And I said to him, look, I accept your apology. We'll be friends. But, more importantly, I want you to forget it, go on with your life. You cannot look back. Here he pauses, and I figure he's finished. But he's groping behind his aviator sunglasses for the point of his anecdote. That forgiveness is ultimately less self-destructive than the bitter desire for revenge, or perhaps that there's no such thing as revenge.
我对他说，听着，我接受你的道歉。我们会成为朋友。但更重要的是，我希望你忘记它，继续你的生活。你不能回头。这里他停顿了一下，我以为他讲完了。但他正在他的飞行员太阳镜后面寻找他轶事的重点。那种宽恕最终比痛苦的复仇欲望更少自我毁灭，或者也许根本就没有复仇这回事。
Five months ago, David Ifshin was diagnosed with cancer. The cancer has proved untreatable and has spread rapidly. David Ifshin is now dying. He's 47 years old and has a wife and three young children. Says McCain, when I heard about it, it did pass through my mind. Suppose I had told David Ifshin to get the hell out of my office? How would I feel about myself now?
五个月前，大卫·伊夫辛被诊断出患有癌症。癌症已无法治疗并迅速扩散。大卫·伊夫辛现在濒临死亡。他47岁，有妻子和三个年幼的孩子。麦凯恩说，当我听说这件事时，它确实闪过我的脑海。假设我当时叫大卫·伊夫辛滚出我的办公室？我现在会如何看待自己？
April 23rd, I'm walking out the door of my Washington apartment, on my way to find David Ifshin, when John McCain calls. I made the mistake of telling his press secretary what I'm up to, and she's passed it along to the senator, who is seriously concerned. He says, look, I don't mean to insult you but be careful with this. If you wrote anything that hurt David, or Gail, or the kids, I'd never forgive myself. I'd forgive you, but I wouldn't forgive myself.
4月23日，我正走出华盛顿公寓的门，准备去找大卫·伊夫辛，这时约翰·麦凯恩打来了电话。我犯了个错误，告诉了他的新闻秘书我要做什么，她转告给了参议员，他非常担心。他说，听着，我不是想侮辱你，但这件事要小心。如果你写了任何伤害大卫、盖尔或孩子们的话，我永远不会原谅自己。我会原谅你，但我不会原谅自己。
It's a half hour drive out of Washington to the Ifshin's house in the Maryland suburbs, where I find a gaunt, bearded man stretched out on a patio lounge chair, attended by his wife Gail. This afternoon, he's tired, and his voice is barely audible as he sketches his political career. The cover of Life Magazine of April 23, 1971 shows David Ifshin, age 22, at a war rally wearing a collegiate goatee. He's standing directly behind Jane Fonda, who has her fist raised. After his war protest, he worked on a kibbutz.
开车从华盛顿到马里兰郊区的伊夫辛家需要半小时，我在那里发现一个消瘦、留着胡子的男人躺在露台的躺椅上，由他的妻子盖尔照顾。今天下午，他很累，声音微弱得几乎听不见，他勾勒了自己的政治生涯。1971年4月23日的《生活》杂志封面显示，22岁的大卫·伊夫辛在一次战争集会上留着大学生的山羊胡。他站在简·方达（Jane Fonda）的正后方，她举着拳头。抗议战争后，他在一个基布兹工作。
But when he returned to America, he also returned in national politics. He went on to work on the Mondale campaign and, to a storm of protest, was even tapped to head the Dukakis transition team. He spent 10 years as general counsel to AIPAC, the Israeli lobby.
但当他回到美国时，他也回到了全国政治中。他继续为蒙代尔竞选团队工作，并在激烈的抗议声中，甚至被选中领导杜卡基斯（Dukakis）过渡团队。他担任了10年美国以色列公共事务委员会（AIPAC）的法律总顾问。
He'd met Clinton briefly in 1972. 20 years later, when Clinton ran for President, Ifshin became general counsel for his campaign. Before he accepted the job however, he told Clinton he'd been attacked for his war record each time he'd joined a presidential campaign. He says, I brought it up with Clinton deliberately. And he said, he knew what I'd done, and he admired it then, and that he still admired it now.
他在1972年见过克林顿。20年后，当克林顿竞选总统时，伊夫辛成为他竞选团队的法律总顾问。然而在他接受这份工作之前，他告诉克林顿，他每次参加总统竞选时都会因战争记录受到攻击。他说，我有意向克林顿提起了这件事。他说，他知道我做过什么，他当时很钦佩，而且他现在依然钦佩。
These days, Clinton calls Ifshin two or three times each week, even when he's traveling. A few months ago, the Ifshin family spent the night in the Lincoln Bedroom. In pictures of Clinton playing with the Ifshin children, the President's ruddy good health seems almost obscene besides Ifshin's drawn face. Yet, when I called him , David Ifshin did not hesitate to rise to the occasion.
这些天，克林顿每周给伊夫辛打两三次电话，即使是在出差时也是如此。几个月前，伊夫辛一家在林肯卧室住了一晚。在克林顿与伊夫辛孩子们玩耍的照片中，总统红润的好气色在伊夫辛憔悴的脸庞旁显得近乎猥琐。然而，当我给他打电话时，大卫·伊夫辛毫不犹豫地应约接受采访。
He says, I'm very proud of this story, and it's never been written. I ask him about his feelings towards McCain. He says, one of our true, political heroes. He's a giant. Ifshin's version of their story differs from McCain's in its important details and in its spirit.
他说，我为这个故事感到自豪，而且它从未被写出来过。我问他对比麦凯恩的感受。他说，他是我们真正的政治英雄之一。他是一个巨人。伊夫辛对他们故事的版本在重要细节和精神上与麦凯恩的有所不同。
The way McCain tells it, Ifshin is the hero. He decided he made a mistake and bravely took responsibility for his actions. The way Ifshin tells is, McCain is the hero. As I listen to him, I realize that this is the reverse of the usual Washington investigation, in which the reporter visits each interested party to collect the dirt on the adversary. Here is a case where each is needed to explain the other's nobility of spirit. I've never heard two political allies, much less two political opponents, cast each other in a more flattering light.
按照麦凯恩的说法，伊夫辛是英雄。他决定自己犯了个错误，并勇敢地为自己的行为承担了责任。按照伊夫辛的说法，麦凯恩是英雄。当我听他讲述时，我意识到这与通常的华盛顿调查相反，通常记者会拜访每一位当事人来收集对手的黑料。这是一个双方都需要对方来解释自己精神高尚的案例。我从未听过两个政治盟友，更不用说两个政治对手，以如此赞美的光芒来评价对方。
Ifshin begins, I'd always wanted to apologize but didn't know who to apologize to. His moment to act, he decided, came at an AIPAC meeting around 1986 at the Washington Hilton. Ifshin spotted Senator John McCain at a distance and decided that he was the man who deserved the apology.
伊夫辛开始说，我一直想道歉，但不知道该向谁道歉。他决定行动的时机是在1986年左右华盛顿希尔顿酒店举行的一次AIPAC会议上。伊夫辛在远处发现了约翰·麦凯恩参议员，并决定他就是那个值得道歉的人。
Ifshin says, I hoisted up my courage and went over to him. And before I could get a word out, McCain says, I owe you an apology. A couple of years earlier, during the 1984 presidential campaign, McCain had given a speech in which he attacked the Ifshin's war record. Basically, someone had handed him a script, says Ifshin, and he read it. He was sorry he did it and said, he wouldn't do that kind of thing again.
伊夫辛说，我鼓起勇气走过去。还没等我开口，麦凯恩就说，我欠你一个道歉。几年前，在1984年总统大选期间，麦凯恩发表了一次演讲，攻击了伊夫辛的战争记录。伊夫辛说，基本上是有人递给他一个剧本，他就照着读了。他对自己做过的事感到后悔，并说他不会再那样做了。
Then he asked me to stop by his office, which I did. And normally wouldn't do. It was blind fate, I told him at that time. I said, I showed you an apology, and you robbed me of the chance to make it. And he was characteristically modest and humble about it. Later that year, McCain and Ifshin, together with a Vietnamese emigre named Doan Van Toai, established The Institute for Democracy in Vietnam.
然后他让我去他的办公室，我就去了。通常我不会这么做。那真是天意，我当时对他说了。我说，我欠你一个道歉，而你剥夺了我道歉的机会。他表现得非常谦虚。那年晚些时候，麦凯恩和伊夫辛与一位名叫段文泰（Doan Van Toai）的越南移民共同建立了越南民主研究所。
Ifshin shifts painfully in his chair and stops to catch his breath. It was at the Vietnam's Veteran Memorial that, what he calls, the second half of the story with McCain began. On Memorial Day of 1993, Bill Clinton spoke at the site. Both McCain and Ifshin were present. Clinton was cheered loudly. He was also heckled. And one of the hecklers waved a sign that said, tell us about Ifshin. Four weeks later, Ifshin found himself on a flight to Washington with McCain, who motioned for him to take the seat beside him. Ifshin says, he asked why I hadn't taken a job in the administration. I said this and that. We played 20 questions until, finally, he said, it's because of that stupid sign isn't it? And I said, yes, partly it was. And he said, come to my office tomorrow morning, and we'll settle this thing, once and for all.
伊夫辛在椅子上痛苦地挪动身体，停下来喘口气。就是在越南退伍军人纪念碑，他所称的与麦凯恩故事的后半部分开始了。1993年阵亡将士纪念日，比尔·克林顿在现场发表了演讲。麦凯恩和伊夫辛都在场。克林顿受到了热烈的欢呼，也遭到了起哄。其中一个起哄者挥舞着标语写道：告诉我们关于伊夫辛的事。四周后，伊夫辛发现自己和麦凯恩在一架飞往华盛顿的飞机上，麦凯恩示意他在身边坐下。伊夫辛说，他问我为什么没在政府谋职。我说了些这啊那啊的。我们玩了20个问题游戏，最后，他说，是因为那个愚蠢的标语，对吧？我说，是的，部分原因是。他说，明天早上来我办公室，我们要一劳永逸地解决这件事。
The next day, June 30th, 1993, David Ifshin turned up in John McCain's office in the Russell Senate Office Building to find that the senator had drafted a letter, which he entered later that day in the Congressional Record. It began by praising Clinton's Memorial Day address on behalf of Vietnam's veterans.
第二天，1993年6月30日，大卫·伊夫辛出现在拉塞尔参议院办公大楼的约翰·麦凯恩办公室，发现参议员起草了一封信，并在当天晚些时候将其录入国会记录。信的开头赞扬了克林顿在阵亡将士纪念日代表越南退伍军人发表的演讲。
The veterans, McCain wrote, were very impressed by Clinton's determination to offer an eloquent tribute to their service, when it would have been far easier for him to avoided the event altogether. McCain decried the behavior of the protesters. Then he moved on.
麦凯恩写道，退伍军人们对克林顿的决心印象深刻，他为他们的服役提供了雄辩的致敬，而他本来可以完全避开这个活动。麦凯恩谴责了抗议者的行为。然后他继续说道。
Among the demonstrators that day, one individual held a sign, which asked the President to explain his association with the person known to many of our colleagues, Mr. David Ifshin. Tell us about Ifshin, it read. My other purpose in speaking today is to do just that. I want to talk about David Ifshin. David Ifshin is my friend. This declaration may come as a shock to those people whose perception of David was-- [AUDIO TRAILS OFF]
那天在示威者中，有一个人举着牌子，要求总统解释他与许多同事熟知的某个人——大卫·伊夫辛先生——的关系。上面写着“告诉我们关于伊夫辛的事”。我今天发言的另一个目的正是为了做这件事。我想谈谈大卫·伊夫辛。大卫·伊夫辛是我的朋友。这个声明可能会让那些对大卫看法是—— [音频淡出]
Well, in the weeks after that was published, David Ifshin died, and John McCain became a leading Vice Presidential contender, after Jack Kemp. It was John McCain who nominated Bob Dole, gave the speech for that at the Republican National Convention. And Michael Lewis ran into McCain on election day.
在那篇报道发表后的几周里，大卫·伊夫辛去世了，约翰·麦凯恩在杰克·坎普（Jack Kemp）之后成为了副总统候选人的主要竞争者。是约翰·麦凯恩提名了鲍勃·多尔，并在共和党全国代表大会上为他发表了演讲。迈克尔·刘易斯在大选日遇到了麦凯恩。
It was funny, at the Dole campaign, everywhere you went with the Dole campaign, senators and governors would come out of the woodwork, because they wanted to have their picture taken, show support, all the rest until the final day. And they all cleared out. No senators or governors were traveling with them. There was one person at his side, and it was John McCain.
很有趣，在多尔竞选期间，无论你跟多尔竞选团队去哪里，参议员和州长都会从四面八方冒出来，因为他们想拍照、表示支持，所有这一切直到最后一天。然后他们都撤了。没有参议员或州长随行。他身边只有一个人，那就是约翰·麦凯恩。
And I was in Russell, Kansas when the Dole campaign came through. I noticed this. I saw McCain off to one side. He'd been with Dole all day. And I went up to talk to him. And he said to me, almost apologetically, he said, you know I wouldn't be here if I thought he was going to win. And I knew that. I mean, he was there, because he knew that it was Dole's time of need. And it was time for someone to step up.
多尔竞选团队经过堪萨斯州拉塞尔时，我也在那里。我注意到了这一点。我看到麦凯恩在一旁。他整天都和多尔在一起。我走过去和他谈话。他近乎抱歉地对我说，你知道如果我认为他会赢，我就不会在这里了。我明白了。我的意思是，他在那里，因为他知道这是多尔最需要的时候。是时候有人站出来了。
And this is what's so curious about McCain. I mean, I think that he continually, as I cover this campaign-- I was new to politics when I came into this campaign. I had never written about politics. I found that McCain restored my faith in the process again and again.
这就是麦凯恩最令人好奇的地方。我的意思是，在报道这场竞选时——我进入这场竞选时对政治还是新手。我从未写过关于政治的文章。我发现麦凯恩一次又一次地恢复了我对这个过程的信心。
It was something about his-- how should I put it-- it was his willingness to stick his neck out for a losing or an unpopular cause that was so different from most of the people who do what he does for a living. So different from the ordinary political attitude that it was refreshing and inspiring.
那是关于他的某种东西——我该怎么说呢——他愿意为一个失败的或不受欢迎的事业挺身而出，这与大多数靠这份职业为生的人是如此不同。这与普通的政治态度是如此不同，以至于让人耳目一新，倍受鼓舞。
Michael Lewis, his campaign diaries from the 1996 race are collected in his book, Trail Fever . John McCain is now running for the Republican presidential nomination.
迈克尔·刘易斯，他1996年大选的竞选日记收录在他的书《竞选狂热》（Trail Fever）中。约翰·麦凯恩现在正在竞选共和党总统提名。
Act Two, Kiss and Tell. Now this story of political idealism, political activism, and political deceit.
第二幕，“亲吻与讲述”。现在是这个关于政治理想主义、政治活动和政治欺骗的故事。
Hello, my name is Dan Savage, and I am the Republican Party in my neighborhood. I am the Republican Precinct Committee Officer, PCO, for precinct 1846 in the 43rd district in Seattle, Washington. If you have any questions about the Republican Party, our platform, or any of our candidates, feel free to give me a call.
你好，我叫丹·萨维奇（Dan Savage），我是我社区的共和党人。我是华盛顿州西雅图第43区第1846选区的共和党选区委员会官员（PCO）。如果你对共和党、我们的纲领或我们的任何候选人有任何疑问，欢迎随时打电话给我。
Now, I should point out here that Dan Savage is not just a Republican precinct committee officer, he's also a gay sex columnist, a drag queen, and someone who agrees with none of the principles of the Republican Party.
现在我应该指出，丹·萨维奇不仅是一位共和党选区委员会官员，他还是位同性恋性专栏作家、变装皇后，且不同意共和党的任何原则。
Now you're probably wondering how a commie-pinko, drag-fag, sex advice columnist found a home in the hate mongering, gay bashing, neo-fascist Republican Party. Well, let me tell you something pal. The Republican Party is a big tent, a huge tent. There were no ideological litmus tests at the Republican Party caucuses or conventions that I attended.
你现在可能在想，一个共产主义粉红、变装异类、性建议专栏作家怎么会在仇恨、打压同性恋、新法西斯主义的共和党中找到归宿。好吧，让我告诉你一件事，伙计。共和党是一个大帐篷，一个巨大的帐篷。我参加的共和党党团会议或代表大会上没有任何意识形态的纯洁性测试。
I didn't have to produce a voter registration card or a picture ID even in my very first caucus. A measure, I believe, of the respect the Republican Party has for the rights of the individual. I just walked through the door, signed on the dotted line. Dan Savage certifies that he she considers himself herself a Republican, and that was it. Who knew that going over to the dark side could be so a simple.
即使是在我的第一次党团会议上，我也不需要出示选民登记卡或带照片的身份证。我相信，这是共和党对个人权利尊重的体现。我只是走过大门，在虚线上签字。丹·萨维奇证明他/她认为自己是共和党人，就这样了。谁知道走向黑暗面会如此简单。
OK, here's the story. Back when Pat Buchanan was posting first and second place showings in Republican primaries this year, Dan Savage got it into his head that the only way to change a political party, that he not only disagreed with but also hated and feared, was to sign up and change it from the inside. So he showed up at his local Republican caucus, which in the 43rd is a small group of Republican holdovers in a big gay neighborhood. And at this point his story took a surprising turn.
好的，故事是这样的。回到帕特·布坎南（Pat Buchanan）今年在共和党初选中取得第一和第二名的时候，丹·萨维奇萌生了一个想法：改变一个他不仅不同意而且还讨厌和恐惧的政党的唯一方法，就是加入并从内部改变它。于是他出现在当地的共和党党团会议上，在第43区，这是一群大同性恋社区中的共和党余部。此时，他的故事发生了意想不到的转折。
Once he arrived, he found out that because he was the only person from the little precinct that he lives in, each caucus is divided up into a lot of little precincts, because of that he was automatically made a precinct committee officer. And then automatically won a seat at the county Republican convention. Well, he wrote up the experience that he had at the caucus in the most damning, partisan tone humanly possible and published it in the paper. But, as he found out, his adventure had barely begun.
一旦到达，他发现因为他是他居住的小选区里唯一的人——每个党团会议都被分成很多小选区——所以他自动成为了选区委员会官员。然后自动赢得了一个参加县共和党代表大会的席位。嗯，他以最严厉、最党派性的语气写下了他在党团会议上的经历，并在报纸上发表了。但是，正如他所发现的那样，他的冒险才刚刚开始。
A couple of weeks after I'd traveled over to the dark side, Daniel Mead Smith, Chairman of the 43rd Republican Party, wrote me a letter. I think you'll be surprised that the hate mongering, gay bashing, neo-fascist, Republican Party does not exist in the 43rd, Smith wrote. I invite you to come to one of our meetings and see for yourself. So I went to one of Smith's meetings to see for myself, the 43rd district Republican caucus.
在我走向黑暗面几周后，第43区共和党主席丹尼尔·米德·史密斯（Daniel Mead Smith）给我写了一封信。史密斯写道，我想你会惊讶地发现，仇恨、打压同性恋、新法西斯主义的共和党在第43区并不存在。我邀请你参加我们的一次会议，亲自看看。于是我参加了史密斯的一次会议，亲自去看了看第43区共和党党团会议。
I arrived at the Montlake Community Center for the 1996, 43rd district, Republican caucuses at 8:00 AM. I paid my $5, signed in, grabbed a seat, and waited for the work to begin. We were there to elect delegates to the state Republican convention coming up Memorial Day weekend and vote on non-binding resolutions.
我于上午8点到达蒙特莱克社区中心参加1996年第43区共和党党团会议。我付了5美元，签到，找了个座位，等待工作开始。我们到那里是为了选出即将到来的阵亡将士纪念日周末的州共和党代表大会的代表，并对非约束性决议进行投票。
The caucus began with a prayer. We ask God to guide us in selecting delegates. And then we were ready to pledge allegiance to the Flag. Only trouble was, no one brought a flag. I thought about suggesting we pledge allegiance to the fag, hey that's me, but I didn't want to be disruptive. Someone found some red, white, and blue bunting in the back room, tossed it over an easel, and we pledged allegiance to that. The easel was needed post-pledge, so the red, white, and blue bunting, to which we had just pledged our allegiance, was tossed on the floor.
党团会议以祈祷开始。我们祈求上帝引导我们选择代表。然后我们准备向国旗宣誓。唯一的问题是，没人带旗子。我想建议我们向“同性恋（fag）”宣誓——嘿，那是我——但我不想造成破坏。有人在后面的房间里找到了一些红白蓝相间的彩带，把它扔在一个画架上，我们就向它宣誓效忠。宣誓后需要用到画架，所以我们刚向其宣誓效忠的红白蓝彩带就被扔到了地板上。
We had to elect delegates, before we could get to the resolutions. I won't bore you with the Robert's Rules of Order stuff, or the impossibly convoluted process by which the 80 of us is that cramped, steeple-roofed, fluorescent lit room elected 17 delegates to the state Republican convention. Suffice to say, it was crushing dull.
在处理决议之前，我们必须选出代表。我就不拿罗伯特议事规则那些东西，或者我们这80人在那个拥挤、屋顶陡峭、荧光灯闪烁的房间里选出17名州共和党代表大会代表的错综复杂的程序来烦你了。总之，非常无聊。
To entertain us while we waited for the ballots to be counted four times, Republican Party activists and candidates gave little speeches. Some of these speeches were pure fantasy. One woman read a prepared speech about the United Nations working in concert with abortionists to take over the country. The other recurring fantasy had to do with us, 43rd district Republicans, retaking the 43rd for the Republican party. One man reminisced about the time, not too long ago, when the 43rd was a solidly Republican district. We can make this district Republican again, just like it was when I joined the party 25 years ago. All we have to do is get out there and doorbell, and identify the voters in this district who are sympathetic to our issues.
为了在我们等待四次计票时娱乐大家，共和党活动家和候选人发表了简短的演讲。其中一些演讲纯属幻想。一位女士读了一篇关于联合国与堕胎者合作接管国家的准备好的讲稿。另一个反复出现的幻想与我们第43区的共和党人有关，即夺回第43区。一个人回忆起不久前第43区还是一个铁杆共和党选区的时候。我们可以让这个选区再次成为共和党选区，就像我25年前加入该党时一样。我们所要做的就是走出去，挨家挨户敲门，找出这个选区里同情我们议题的选民。
Heart pounding, I stuck my hand in the air. Have any of you been out of the house or walked down Broadway in the last 25 years, I asked, standing and looking around at the toughest crowd I've probably ever played. The 43rd district, I pointed out, had gone all gay, all of the sudden. So long as the Republican Party was identified with homophobes and anti-gay bigot activists, the Republican Party could kiss the 43rd district goodbye.
心跳加速，我举起了手。我问，站起来环顾四周，看着我所见过的最难缠的人群，你们过去25年里有没有出过门或在百老汇街上走过？我指出，第43区突然全变成了同性恋。只要共和党还被贴上恐同和反同性恋偏执狂活动家的标签，共和党就可以跟第43区说再见了。
When I sat down a little old lady sitting behind me pointed out that she knew a very nice gay couple in the Republican Party. In other words, she, and by extension the Party, was not homophobic. And I was wrong. She said to me, the Party isn't against gay people. That's just a false impression you have.
当我坐下时，坐在我身后的一位老太太指出，她认识共和党内一对非常好的同性恋夫妇。换句话说，她，进而整个党，并非恐同。而我是错的。她对我说，该党并不反对同性恋。那只是你有的一个错误印象。
Gee, I wonder where I could have picked up that false impression, maybe from Jesse Helms, Bob Dornan, Bob $1,000 Dole, anti-gay rights rallies in Iowa during the primaries attended by all the Republican presidential hopefuls even moderate Lamar Alexander, Pat Robertson, Ralph Reed, Newt Gingrich, Linda Smith, Ellen Craswell, Spokane county corner Dexter Amend, the Washington State Legislature, state legislatures all across the country, the Christian Coalition--
天哪，我想知道我怎么会产生那种错误印象，也许是从杰西·赫尔姆斯（Jesse Helms）、鲍勃·多尔南（Bob Dornan）、鲍勃·“1000美元”·多尔那里，从初选期间爱荷华州所有共和党总统候选人参加的反同性恋权利集会上，甚至温和派拉马尔·亚历山大（Lamar Alexander）、帕特·罗伯逊（Pat Robertson）、拉尔夫·里德（Ralph Reed）、纽特·金里奇（Newt Gingrich）、琳达·史密斯（Linda Smith）、艾伦·克拉斯韦尔（Ellen Craswell）、斯波坎县验尸官德克斯特·阿曼德（Dexter Amend）、华盛顿州立法机构、全国各地的州立法机构、基督教联盟——
During a break, an attractive, middle aged man approached me. He was a little angry. I was offended by you forcing me to take responsibility for Jesse Helms. As if the Republican Party isn't responsible for Jesse Helms. One woman wanted to know why she should support gay people, since gay people didn't support her when her home was burned down by arsonists. The arsonists weren't gay or anything, but where were gay people when she needed them. Another pointed out that some gays had broken the windows of the Republican Party headquarters, so who's oppressing who?
休息期间，一位有魅力的中年男子走近我。他有点生气。你强迫我为杰西·赫尔姆斯承担责任，这让我感到冒犯。好像共和党不对杰西·赫尔姆斯负责一样。一位女士想知道她为什么要支持同性恋，因为当她的家被纵火犯烧毁时，同性恋并没有支持她。纵火犯不是同性恋什么的，但当她需要帮助时，同性恋在哪里？另一个人指出，一些同性恋打破了共和党总部的窗户，所以到底是谁在压迫谁？
Another man took me aside during a break to let me know that the gay bashing within the Republican Party wasn't for real. It was only to get out the vote and motivate the frontlines. Well then, I guess that makes it OK. I'm happy to be vilified, and scapegoated, and denied my civil rights so long as it motivates people to go to the polls. Disenfranchisement is a small price to pay to increase voter turnout.
另一名男子在休息期间把我拉到一边，让我知道共和党内部对同性恋的攻击不是真的。这只是为了拉票和激励前线。好吧，我想那让它变得可以接受了。只要能激励人们去投票，我很乐意被诽谤、被当成替罪羊和被剥夺公民权利。被剥夺选举权是增加选民投票率的一小点代价。
To his surprise, at this meeting, Dan Savage talked the caucus into approving a resolution that affirmed the rights of gays and lesbians, and rejected elements of the party who would exploit fear and hatred of homosexuals for short term political gain. He could not wait, after this victory, to get to the county convention.
令他惊讶的是，在这次会议上，丹·萨维奇说服党团会议批准了一项决议，肯定了同性恋者的权利，并拒绝了党内那些为了短期政治利益而利用对同性恋者的恐惧和仇恨的分子。这次胜利后，他迫不及待地想要去县代表大会。
As an official delegate, Dan Savage would be allowed to vote there, he'd be allowed to make amendments, he'd really be allowed to play a role. He planned to vote in the straw polls they have at these things for the most conservative Republican candidates. In this case, Pat Buchanan for President and for the Governor of Washington State, he was going to vote for Ellen Craswell, who opposes gun control, and gay rights, and moral decay, and who he loathes. Dan Savage's thinking was that the more extreme the Republican ticket would end up being, the more likely they would lose in the general election, and the more likely that the Party would eventually abandon this more conservative wing.
作为正式代表，丹·萨维奇可以在那里投票，他可以提出修正案，他真的可以在其中发挥作用。他计划在这些场合的民意测验中投票给最保守的共和党候选人。在这种情况下，他要投给帕特·布坎南竞选总统，对于华盛顿州州长，他要投给艾伦·克拉斯韦尔，她反对枪支管制、同性恋权利和道德沦丧，也是他所厌恶的人。丹·萨维奇的想法是，共和党的竞选票据越极端，他们在大选中失败的可能性就越大，该党最终放弃这个更保守派别的可能性也就越大。
A few weeks later, the big day arrived, the King County Republican Convention. My first major party function, hats, speeches, amendments. I bounded out of bed at 7:00 AM-- ew-- and ran to meet my new friend Steve at the QFC on Broadway. Steve attended his precinct caucuses way back in March with the intention of getting himself elected a delegate to the county and state Republican conventions. Like me, he joined the Republican Party out of a sincere desire to move the GOP to the center. Kindred spirits, we decided to attend the county convention together.
几周后，大日子到了，金县（King County）共和党代表大会。我的第一个大型党派活动，帽子、演讲、修正案。我早上7点从床上跳起来——噢——跑去百老汇的QFC超市见我的新朋友史蒂夫。史蒂夫早在三月就参加了他的选区党团会议，目的是让自己当选为县和州共和党代表大会的代表。像我一样，他出于推动共和党向中间靠拢的真诚愿望加入了共和党。志同道合，我们决定一起参加县代表大会。
The doors opened at 7:30 AM. After the crowd settled down, a preacher read an alarming opening invocation, which pretty much set the tone for what was to come. Please forgive our leaders for endorsing perversion, and God deliver us from some spineless compromise. Then we bellowed the Pledge of Allegiance to the Flag of the United States of America. I slipped up to the merchandise tables on the second floor, where I bought myself a red, white, and blue Craswell for Governor hat. It must've been fate. On my way back down from the merchandise tables, I ran smack dab into Ellen Craswell herself.
大门在早上7点30分打开。人群平静下来后，一位牧师宣读了一段令人不安的开幕祈祷，这基本上为接下来的一切定下了基调。请原谅我们的领导人支持变态，求上帝将我们从毫无骨气的妥协中拯救出来。然后我们高呼向美利坚合众国国旗宣誓效忠。我溜到二楼的商品摊位，给自己买了一顶红白蓝相间的“克拉斯韦尔竞选州长”帽子。那一定是天意。在我从商品摊回来的路上，我正好撞见了艾伦·克拉斯韦尔本人。
I said, hello. And looking very serious in my little red, white, and blue hat asked, what are we going to do about the homosexual problem Ms. Craswell? What is the final solution to all this homosexual nonsense? So long as they stay inside, we can let them alone, Ellen Craswell confided in me. But when they organize and demand special rights, we must oppose them. We can't give special rights to something that is an abomination in the eyes of God.
我说，你好。戴着我的小红白蓝帽子，表情非常严肃地问道，克拉斯韦尔女士，我们要如何解决同性恋问题？这一切同性恋荒唐事最终的解决方案是什么？艾伦·克拉斯韦尔向我吐露，只要他们待在里面，我们可以让他们单独待着。但当他们组织起来并要求特殊权利时，我们必须反对他们。我们不能把特殊权利给那种在上帝眼中是可憎的东西。
Now, Ellen didn't seem interested in elaborating on just what it is we're supposed to stay inside of. The closet, are apartments, the priesthood? So I said, goodbye, promising to vote for her in the primary. You see, the better Ellen does in the primary, the better the Democratic candidate for governor will do in the fall.
嗯，艾伦似乎对我们要待在什么里面不感兴趣。衣柜、公寓、神职？所以我说，再见，并承诺在初选中投她一票。你看，艾伦在初选中表现得越好，民主党州长候选人在秋季的表现就会越好。
I made it back to the convention floor just in time for the opening debate on the party platform. The King County Republican platform is a document drawn up by committee that lays out what the King County Republican Party stands for. And here's the beautiful part. Delegates are allowed to propose amendments. Once an amendment is proposed, the amendment's sponsor is allowed to speak, followed by a few people in favor, a few opposed. After that, the sponsor gets another minute or so to address the floor. I was a delegate. I had amendments. And so I would get to address the convention over, and over, and over again. And, as amendments are time consuming, determined delegates can grind the convention to a halt.
我及时赶回了代表大会会场，正好赶上党纲的开幕辩论。金县共和党纲领是由委员会起草的一份文件，阐明了金县共和党的主张。这才是最美妙的部分。代表们可以提出修正案。一旦修正案提出，修正案的发起人可以发言，随后是几个赞成的人，几个反对的人。在那之后，发起人还有一分钟左右的时间向大会发言。我是代表。我有修正案。所以我可以一遍又一遍地向大会发言。而且，由于修正案很耗时，坚定的代表们可以让代表大会陷入停顿。
The first section we were to vote on was the preamble, in which we acknowledged God to be our creator, and the family is the foundation of our culture. We embraced free markets, recognized that tax and regulatory burdens are a threat to our freedoms, yada, yada, yada. Before we could vote on the preamble, and it hadn't occurred to me to amend the preamble, a delegate propose that a line be added stating that the Party was open to all who accept its basic principles regardless of race, religion, sex, or national origin.
我们要投票的第一部分是序言，我们在其中承认上帝是我们的创造者，家庭是我们文化的基石。我们拥护自由市场，认识到税收和监管负担是对我们自由的威胁，等等等等。在我们能够对序言进行投票之前——我没想到要修改序言——一位代表提议增加一行，声明该党对所有接受其基本原则的人开放，无论种族、宗教、性别或国籍。
After debate, the first resolution of the day passed by a distressingly narrow margin. Race, creed, sex, national origin, something was missing. Steve approached the microphone and proposed that the just passed amendment also be amended to include the words sexual orientation. Well, Steve's amendment was soundly defeated by voice vote that, though untabulated, sounded to me like a 1,589 to 11.
辩论后，当天的第一项决议以令人不安的微弱优势通过。种族、信仰、性别、国籍，少了点什么。史蒂夫走到麦克风前，提议刚才通过的修正案也应增加“性取向”字样。嗯，史蒂夫的修正案在语音投票中被彻底否决，虽然没有统计，但我听起来像是1589比11。
Then the liberty section was up for a vote. I dashed to a microphone, wearing my Ellen Craswell hat, and proposed this amendment. As respect for the rights of the individual are the bedrock of Republican values, the King County Republican Party hereby recognizes the fundamental human rights of gay and lesbian American citizens. We reject elements on the fringe of the Republican Party that would exploit fear and hatred of gay and lesbian American citizens for short term political gain.
然后轮到自由部分的投票。我冲向麦克风，戴着艾伦·克拉斯韦尔的帽子，提出了这个修正案。由于尊重个人权利是共和党价值观的基石，金县共和党在此承认男女同性恋美国公民的基本人权。我们拒绝共和党边缘中那些为了短期政治利益而利用对男女同性恋美国公民的恐惧和仇恨的分子。
Through the shouting, I pointed out that we King County Republicans can't have it both ways. We can't say in one breath that we oppose discrimination, and with our next breath support discrimination against gay and lesbian American citizens. So let's vote on it. Do we, the Republicans of King County, recognize the fundamental rights of gay and lesbian American citizens, or do we not?
在喧哗中，我指出我们金县共和党人不能两全其美。我们不能一方面说我们反对歧视，另一方面又支持对男女同性恋美国公民的歧视。所以让我们投票表决吧。我们，金县的共和党人，是承认男女同性恋美国公民的基本权利，还是不承认？
Well, we do not. After some heated debate, the names I was called-- pervert, sodomite, Democrat-- my amendment was voted down. After my amendment failed, a woman in a Craswell hat approached me. Why are you wearing that hat, she briskly inquired.
嗯，我们不承认。在激烈的辩论后——我被骂的名字：变态、鸡奸者、民主党人——我的修正案被投票否决了。我的修正案失败后，一位戴着克拉斯韦尔帽子的女士走近我。你为什么要戴那顶帽子，她严厉地问。
Because I'm for Craswell. You know where she stands on gay things, don't you? Having recently had a conversation with Ellen herself, I most certainly did. But I'm not, I smilingly inform my new friend and fellow Craswell supporter, a single issue voter.
因为我支持克拉斯韦尔。你知道她对同性恋持什么立场，对吧？由于最近亲自与艾伦谈过，我当然知道。但我微笑着告诉我的新朋友和克拉斯韦尔支持者，我不是单议题选民。
Try to imagine, now, that you're a homophobic, Republican jerk-off, which might be a triple redundancy, at your county convention. You came for the speeches, an anti-Clinton t-shirt for your collection, and a hot dog. This is what you do for fun, woo hoo. But these three guys keep introducing pro-gay rights amendments, moving to have anti-gay amendments struck, and generally messing with your afternoon.
现在，试着想象一下，你是一个恐同的共和党混蛋——这可能是三重冗余——在你的县代表大会上。你是为了演讲、为你的收藏品买一件反克林顿T恤，还有热狗来的。这就是你娱乐的方式，呜呼。但这三个人一直在提出支持同性恋权利的修正案，要求删除反同性恋的修正案，并普遍捣乱你的下午。
You didn't come to the convention to defend your party's homophobia. And you certainly didn't come expecting to listen to gay men giving speeches all day long. Who are these guys? And why is that one wearing a Craswell hat? OK, you're this person, what do you do? You get mad, very, very mad. One delegate decided to get even. In what can only be described as a David Lynch moment, a palsied delegate staggered up to the microphone and proposed a change in the rules. No further discussion of homosexuality allowed. His resolution needed a 2/3 majority to pass, because it was a rules change, not a simple amendment. And pass it did, to hoots, and hollers, and cheers.
你来参加代表大会不是为了捍卫你党的恐同症。你肯定也没想到要听同性恋者整天演讲。这些人是谁？为什么那个戴着克拉斯韦尔的帽子？好吧，你是这个人，你会怎么做？你很生气，非常、非常生气。一位代表决定报复。在只能被描述为大卫·林奇（David Lynch）时刻的情况下，一位患有震颤麻痹的代表踉踉跄跄地走到麦克风前，提议修改规则。不允许进一步讨论同性恋。他的决议需要2/3多数才能通过，因为这是规则修改，而不是简单的修正案。而它通过了，伴随着嘘声、欢呼声和掌声。
But we had yet to vote on the education section, which contained a plank about homosexuality. When we got to education, all hell broke loose. Robert's Rules of Order fetishists lept to their feet insisting that the anti-gay plank in the education section would have to be struck. If we can't discuss homosexuality, we can't vote on it, for voting is a discussion. Uh oh, we were talking about homosexuality again. People were booing, shouting, oh, the humanity.
但我们还没有对教育部分进行投票，其中包含了一项关于同性恋的条款。当我们讨论到教育时，一切都乱套了。《罗伯特议事规则》的狂热分子跳起来坚持认为必须删除教育部分中反同性恋的条款。如果我们不能讨论同性恋，我们就不能投票表决，因为投票就是一种讨论。噢，不，我们又在讨论同性恋了。人们在嘘、在喊，噢，人类。
The chair, bringing the room to order, calmly ruled that the no-further discussion resolution applied only to pro-gay discussions. We could discuss homosexuality, he said, but only if we weren't saying anything nice about it. And the convention limped to a close. Most of the day having been wasted debating gay rights, gay marriage, what makes people gay, and my hat.
会议主席平静地裁定，禁止进一步讨论的决议仅适用于亲同性恋的讨论。我们可以讨论同性恋，他说，但前提是我们不能说关于它的好话。于是代表大会一瘸一拐地结束了。大部分时间都浪费在辩论同性恋权利、同性婚姻、是什么让人变成同性恋以及我的帽子上了。
What I learned. Here's what I learned about Republicans that weekend. They don't like homos very much. They certainly don't like having to talk about us. And they certainly like listening to us even less. But they do like beating up on us in their platforms. So King County Republicans, I'll make you a deal. Leave us out of your platform in '98, the next convention cycle, and I'll stay away from your convention. But if we're in the platform, I intend to return.
我学到了什么。这就是那个周末我学到的关于共和党人的知识。他们不太喜欢同性恋。他们当然不喜欢不得不谈论我们。而且他们听我们说话就更少了。但他们确实喜欢在纲领中攻击我们。所以金县的共和党人，我们做个交易吧。在98年的下一个大会周期，把我们从纲领中剔除，我就远离你们的代表大会。但如果我们还在纲领里，我就打算回去。
Dan Savage writes the syndicated sex advice columns, "Savage Love." And he's the author of several books, most recently, The Kid, What Happened After My Boyfriend and I Decided to get Pregnant an Adoption Story . Dan has continued his activism in the Republican Party, most recently he cast a vote in the Iowa straw-poll for Steve Forbes. His account of that is online. You can link there from the This America Life website at www. Thislife.org
丹·萨维奇撰写了联合辛迪加的性建议专栏“萨维奇的爱”（Savage Love）。他是几本书的作者，最近的一本是《孩子，我男友和我决定怀孕后发生的事情：一个收养故事》（The Kid, What Happened After My Boyfriend and I Decided to get Pregnant an Adoption Story）。丹继续他在共和党内的活动，最近他在爱荷华州的民意测验中把票投给了史蒂夫·福布斯（Steve Forbes）。他关于这件事的描述在线。你可以从“美国生活”网站www.thislife.org链接到那里。
Coming up, illegal aliens who agreed that they should be deported, take matters into their own hands, and other unlikely stories. That's in a minute. From Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，同意应该被遣返的非法移民，采取行动，以及其他不可思议的故事。稍后回来。来自国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program comes in the wake of the first Iowa presidential straw poll. With just 14 months left in the election season, we bring you election stories, hopefully, to restore a sense of hope. All of them taken from election coverage we did on This American Life four years ago during the last big election cycle. We've arrived at act three of our program, Act Three, Pete and Repeat.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目是在爱荷华州首次总统民意测验之后。距离选举季只剩下14个月，我们为你带来选举故事，希望以此恢复一丝希望。所有这些都取自四年前我们在上次大选周期中在《美国生活》上所做的选举报道。我们已经到达节目的第三幕，第三幕，“彼得与重复”。
This is the story of and idealistic political movement, which, like so many, began in California, the self-deportation movement. This was back on the year, back around election day, 1996.
这是一个关于理想主义政治运动的故事，像许多运动一样，它始于加州，即自我遣返运动。那是1996年大选日前后的事。
Hey, Pedro, go back to Mexico. Stop taking our jobs. And stop looking at my daughter.
嘿，佩德罗，滚回墨西哥去。别再抢我们的工作了。还有，别再盯着我女儿看。
Immigrants are you tired of being pushed around in America? Well, don't sit on your serape, do something about it. Join the conservative political action group, HALTO, Hispanics Against Liberal Takeover. I'm the chairman of HALTO, Daniel D. Portado. What is self deportation, do you ask? Think of it as a permanent vacation. Immigrants join hospital today and see your homeland tomorrow. Self-deportation is a trademark of Hispanics Against Liberal Takeover, subject agrees to voluntarily repatriate to native land or Mexico, whichever is the nearest. All self-deportations are final. No exchanges or refunds. Tickets are one-way only.
移民们，你们厌倦了在美国被人指使吗？嗯，别坐在你们的披肩上，采取行动吧。加入保守派政治行动组织HALTO，“反对自由派接管的西班牙裔人”（Hispanics Against Liberal Takeover）。我是HALTO的主席，丹尼尔·D·波塔多（Daniel D. Portado）。你问什么是自我遣返？把它想成是一个永久的假期。移民们今天加入HALTO，明天就去看你的祖国。自我遣返是“反对自由派接管的西班牙裔人”的商标，主体同意自愿遣返回祖国或墨西哥，以最近的为准。所有自我遣返都是最终的。没有交换或退款。车票仅为单程。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语演讲]
While listeners to our program in California may be familiar with this advertisement and with the group, Hispanics Against Liberal Takeover, they are a militant, self-deportation movement, encouraging all minorities to leave the United States. That's right, all minorities. Its founder, Daniel D. Portado, has appeared on Spanish language TV. I actually saw a video of one of these appearances, where, basically, the entire Latino studio audience yelled at him nonstop for his entire appearance.
虽然我们在加州的节目听众可能熟悉这个广告和“反对自由派接管的西班牙裔人”组织，但他们是一个激进的、自我遣返运动，鼓励所有少数族裔离开美国。没错，所有少数族裔。其创始人丹尼尔·D·波塔多曾在西班牙语电视上露面。我确实看过这些出镜中的一段视频，基本上，整个拉丁裔演播室观众在他出镜期间都在不停地对他大喊大叫。
Mr. Portado says that he started his movement when he read newspaper accounts about Mexican Americans who were in favor of California's Proposition 187. Prop 187 was the Proposition that cut off social services to illegal immigrants. He thought these Mexican Americans, who were in favor of cutting off the services, had the right idea but just did not go far enough. They just didn't take it to its logical conclusion. And he felt that self-deportation was the only solution.
波塔多先生说，他发起这项运动时，读到了有关支持加州187号提案的墨西哥裔美国人的报纸报道。187号提案是切断非法移民社会服务的提案。他认为这些支持切断服务的墨西哥裔美国人，想法是对的，只是还不够彻底。他们只是没有将其推向逻辑上的结论。他觉得自我遣返是唯一的解决方案。
We feel that the immigrants are taking too many jobs, are bringing down the quality of life. They're not allowing our young American teenagers the character building experiences of picking fruit and cleaning hotel beds.
我们觉得移民抢占了太多的工作，正在降低生活质量。他们没有让我们的年轻美国青少年获得采摘水果和清理旅馆床位的性格塑造经验。
So what's your evaluation of this week's election results. Were the election results in California good or bad for your self-deportation movement?
那么你对本周选举结果的评价是什么？加州的选举结果对你的自我遣返运动是好还是坏？
Oh well, luckily, Pete Wilson is still with us. Of course, I was the chairman of, originally, of Hispanics for Wilson, the pro 187 group.
哦，好吧，幸运的是，彼得·威尔逊仍然和我们在一起。当然，我最初是“西班牙裔支持威尔逊”组织（那个支持187提案的团体）的主席。
Proposition 187 was the California proposition that suggested, and passed, saying that illegal immigrants could not receive any social services.
187号提案是加州的那个提案，它提议——并获得了通过——说非法移民不能获得任何社会服务。
Right, right, and we are also sponsoring for the next election our own initiative, the Spic and Span Initiative, which stands for, Stop Promoting Illegal Culture and Spanish. Basically, we're trying to prohibit any sort of activity which might attract illegals to this country, such as dancing the "Macarena". That would now be punishable by four Saturdays of freeway pick-up, clean-up, and a $250 fine.
对，对，我们还在为下一次选举赞助我们自己的倡议，“干净利落倡议”（Spic and Span Initiative），它代表：停止促进非法文化和西班牙语（Stop Promoting Illegal Culture and Spanish）。基本上，我们试图禁止任何可能吸引非法移民来这个国家的活动，比如跳“马卡雷纳舞”（Macarena）。这现在将受到四个星期六高速公路清理工作和250美元罚款的惩罚。
Pretty steep.
挺严厉的。
And also saying certain words or any word in Spanish, such as a Los Angeles, California, San Diego--
还有说某些词或任何西班牙语词，比如洛杉矶、加州、圣地亚哥——
Burrito--
墨西哥卷饼（Burrito）——
Burrito, yes, and chorito, all these are traditional-- Things like Linda Ronstadt records would now be banned.
墨西哥卷饼，是的，还有chorito，所有这些都是传统的——像琳达·朗丝黛（Linda Ronstadt）的唱片现在将被禁止。
Those ones where she sings the Mexican songs?
那些她唱墨西哥歌曲的唱片？
Yes, the ones that she doesn't understand what she's singing, but it's very harmful. And it's like a yodel out to the immigrants. It's saying, are you out there? Is is there anyone out there? Would you like to come to America? That's what, basically, Linda Ronstadt is saying.
是的，那些她自己都不懂在唱什么的，但这非常有害。就像对着移民喊麦。它在说，你们在那儿吗？有人在那儿吗？你想来美国吗？琳达·朗丝黛基本上就是这个意思。
When she sings a Spanish language song, you mean she's pulling people across the border with the power of her voice?
当她唱西班牙语歌曲时，你是说她用歌声的力量把人吸引过境？
Yes, it is a major conspiracy. You did not know? Governor Wilson has discovered that there is a major conspiracy to get all sorts of indios from remote villages to come over. I mean, when Clinton says, it takes a village, I mean, he's talking about importing a whole village from Michoacan. Don't you know that?
是的，这是一个巨大的阴谋。你不知道吗？威尔逊州长发现，有一个巨大的阴谋，让各种从偏远村庄来的印第安人过来。我的意思是，当克林顿说，“这需要一个村庄”时，我的意思是，他在谈论从米却肯州引进整个村庄。你不知道吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So, also we have discovered, with the help of Governor Wilson, that the "Macarena" is actually a very sinister mind control device. And it is part of a conspiracy to control the white electorates feeble mind.
所以，我们也发现，在威尔逊州长的帮助下，“马卡雷纳舞”实际上是一种非常邪恶的思维控制装置。它是控制白人选民脆弱头脑的阴谋的一部分。
What do you mean? How do you figure? What is it doing to the white electorate?
你是什么意思？你怎么想的？它对白人选民做了什么？
Well, we actually have a translation here by our researchers that we can read for you.
嗯，我们这里实际上有一份我们研究人员的翻译，我们可以为你读一下。
All right, sure. These are the words to the "Macarena?"
好的，当然。这些是“马卡雷纳”的歌词？
Yes. And so my bodyguard, Rudy Rico, will do the translation in English. And I will read the original lyrics in the soon to be forbidden Spanish tongue. So here we go.
是的。所以我的保镖，鲁迪·里科（Rudy Rico），将用英语进行翻译。我将用即将被禁止的西班牙语舌头朗读原文歌词。所以我们开始吧。
[SPEAKING  SPANISH]
[西班牙语演讲]
I control your mind and body, gringo.
我控制你的思想和身体，老美（gringo）。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语演讲]
Now, it's time to pick the fruit and make me rich.
现在，是时候去采摘水果并让我变富了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语演讲]
Give me the keys to your Volvo, gringo.
把你的沃尔沃车钥匙给我，老美。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语演讲]
Hey, stupid gringo.
嘿，蠢老美。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语演讲]
See how foolish you look.
看看你看起来有多愚蠢。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语演讲]
When you twist and dance to my mind control music.
当你扭动身体跳着我的思维控制音乐时。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语演讲]
Screw the police.
去死吧，警察。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语演讲]
Now go cook some food for my friends.
现在去为我的朋友煮点吃的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语演讲]
Stupid gringos, stupid gringos, stupid gringos.
蠢老美，蠢老美，蠢老美。
So, as you can see, this is a very sinister device.
所以，正如你所见，这是一个非常邪恶的装置。
Daniel D. Portado, if you actually believe in deportation, what are you yourself still doing in California.
丹尼尔·D·波塔多，如果你真的相信遣返，你自己为什么还留在加州？
Well, I am here to help everyone get out. I hope to look forward to the day where I will stand at the border and say, will the last Mexican out of California, please turn out the lights. That will be me.
嗯，我在这里是为了帮助每个人离开。我希望期待有那么一天，我会站在边境上说，最后一个离开加州的墨西哥人，请关灯。那个人会是我。
Daniel D. Portado, chairman of Hispanics Against Liberal Takeover.
丹尼尔·D·波塔多，“反对自由派接管的西班牙裔人”组织主席。
Act  four-- Throwing Money at the Problem. Well, back in 1996, when the Democratic convention came to town here in Chicago, the city did a multi-million cleanup for the convention along the routes between the downtown hotels and the United Center, the sports arena where the convention was held.
第四幕——“用钱砸向问题”。嗯，回到1996年，当民主党代表大会来到芝加哥时，市里在市中心酒店和联合中心（United Center，举行大会的体育场）之间的路线上进行了一次耗资数百万美元的清理活动。
Well one night, after the convention, I jumped in a cab with some other people, strangers, convention goers, and we sped up Monroe Street, them to their hotels, me, back to the radio station. The moon was out, the air was perfect, the street was freshly paved, and a woman from Washington DC, a lobbyist who had attended the convention in a sky box remarked, Chicago is so beautiful. There are no potholes, no homeless people, and the weather is so beautiful.
大会结束后的一天晚上，我和其他人——陌生人、大会参加者——一起上了一辆出租车，我们沿着门罗街疾驰，他们去酒店，我回电台。月亮出来了，空气完美，街道是刚铺好的，一位来自华盛顿特区、参加了包厢会议的说客评论说：芝加哥太美了。没有坑洼，没有无家可归的人，天气也这么好。
Now, don't get me wrong, I love Chicago. But I have to say, we do have our fair share of potholes, homeless people, and bad weather. I knew, before this moment, that money could not buy love, but I had no idea it could buy this level of misperception. This next story is about what all the cameras and all the political elite see in the neighborhoods they drive through, and what they don't see.
现在，别误会，我热爱芝加哥。但我不得不说，我们确实有相当多的坑洼、无家可归者和糟糕的天气。在那一刻之前，我就知道金钱买不到爱，但我没想到它能买到这种程度的误解。接下来的故事是关于所有的摄像机和所有的政治精英在他们开车经过的社区里看到了什么，以及他们没看到什么。
You may remember the bestselling book, There Are No Children Here , from a few years back. In it, writer Alex Kotlowitz described the lives of two brothers at the Henry Horner homes. It was made into a TV film by Oprah Winfrey. It's been mentioned many times in speeches by Jack Kemp and by others. Well, Henry Horner is the public housing project that sits right across the street from the United Center where the convention was held.
你可能还记得几年前那本畅销书《这里没有孩子》。在书中，作家亚历克斯·科特洛维茨（Alex Kotlowitz）描述了亨利·霍纳住宅区的两个兄弟的生活。它被奥普拉·温弗瑞（Oprah Winfrey）拍成了电视电影。杰克·坎普和其他人在演讲中多次提到它。嗯，亨利·霍纳就是那个公共住房项目，就位于举行大会的联合中心对面。
And when Chicago did its multimillion dollar cleanup for the Democratic convention, it cleaned up some of Horner. The boys from Alex Kotlowitz's book are now young men, and they do not live at Horner anymore. But they go back now and then. And during the convention, we asked one of them, Pharoah Walton, who was then 18, to give us a tour of what had changed at Horner because of the convention, and what hadn't changed.
当芝加哥为民主党代表大会进行数百万美元的清理工作时，它也清理了霍纳的部分地区。科特洛维茨书中的男孩现在已经是年轻人了，他们不再住在霍纳了。但他们偶尔会回去。在大会期间，我们请其中一位法老·沃尔顿（Pharoah Walton，当时18岁）带领我们参观霍纳因为大会发生了什么变化，以及什么没变。
And one of the most interesting things about his report is how much of the neighborhood had improved for political and legal reasons, for all sorts of reasons, that never entered our political consciousness. They never became part of any discussion of what's going on in our cities. They never became part of the discussion of how things might be improved. So here, once again, is Pharoah's story.
关于他的报道，最有趣的事情之一是，有多少社区为了政治和法律原因，为了各种各样的原因而得到了改善，这些原因从未进入我们的政治意识。它们从未成为任何关于我们城市正在发生什么事情的讨论的一部分。它们从未成为关于事情如何改善的讨论的一部分。所以，再次呈现法老的报道。
When I left Henry Horner five years ago, it looked like a ghost town. It had no green grass, broken windows, graffiti everywhere. Now, here in Horner, it's a different place. There are rows of flowers outside the maintenance building, and new windows in the office where my mother used to pay rent. There are trees, new elevators. Most of the changes are on the side of the building that faced the United Center. And on Washington Street, where the old Birney school used to be, there's a new playground, with a big lawn and a huge new blue and green jungle gym. Nicer than any playground I've ever seen in the city, even on the Northside, and everyone knows why.
五年前我离开亨利·霍纳时，它看起来像个鬼城。没有绿草，窗户破碎，到处是涂鸦。现在，在这里，在霍纳，这是一个不同的地方。维护大楼外有成排的花朵，我母亲过去交租金的办公室也换了新窗户。有树木，有新电梯。大部分变化是在面对联合中心的那一侧建筑上。而在旧伯尼学校所在的华盛顿街，有一个新的游乐场，有大片草坪和巨大的蓝绿色新丛林健身架。比我在城里见过的任何游乐场都要好，甚至在北区也是，每个人都知道原因。
I like it. It's fun. I know why they did it. Because the President is coming. And then they all be taking kids and they going to be killing people, the President's soldiers.
我喜欢它。它很有趣。我知道他们为什么要这么做。因为总统要来了。然后他们都会带走孩子，总统的士兵将会杀人。
People say a lot of other things too. And not all of them make sense. Like what Kanue Howe told me about the playground.
人们也说了许多其他事情。并不是所有这些话都有道理。比如卡努·豪（Kanue Howe）告诉我的关于游乐场的事。
The Democratic convention coming, and now I can't be outside. [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. After 7:30 [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and if you're not, you're gonna be all [UNINTELLIGIBLE] all you home, then get a doctor. There be a lot of parties in our building and parties not supposed to be in our building.
民主党代表大会要来了，现在我不能在外面了。[无法辨认]。7:30以后[无法辨认]，如果你不在，你会在[无法辨认]，都在你家，然后找个医生。我们楼里会有很多派对，那些派对不应该在我们楼里。
People at Horner are glad about the physical changes. But most of them say they're mad that it took a President before the city would clean up a parking lot or plant a tree. Some things I'm hearing have changed and some things are still the same, like shootings and hot days. But when I was a kid, I would run in the house when the shootings start. Same with my nephew Snuggles and his friend Jeremy today.
霍纳的人们对物理变化感到高兴。但他们大多数人说，他们很生气，因为直到总统到来，城市才愿意清理停车场或种一棵树。我听到有些事情改变了，有些事情依然如故，比如枪击和炎热的天气。但当我还是个孩子时，枪击开始时我会跑进屋里。今天我的侄子斯纳格尔斯（Snuggles）和他的朋友杰里米（Jeremy）也是一样。
They always trying to shoot on a hot day.
他们总是试图在炎热的日子里开枪。
And they start gang banging, when they on a hot day. And then all the kids got to go in the house.
当天气炎热时，他们就会开始团伙火拼。然后所有的孩子都必须进屋。
Like two weeks ago, some boy got shot, he got shot in the eye.
就像两周前，有个男孩被枪击了，他眼睛中弹了。
Probably is dead now.
现在可能已经死了。
He is dead. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] shooting all the time.
他死了。[无法辨认]一直在枪击。
Usually when you here about the projects, you hear that things are bad, and they're getting worse. But when I went to Horner, I heard a different story. There still shootings, still drugs, and still gangs. But, mostly, people told me that things have slowed down. In 1991, the residents of Henry Horner filed a lawsuit against the city and won. Because of that, the Chicago Housing Authority is cleaning it up, renovating old apartments, putting in new elevators, tearing down the worst building. They've moved 233 families out of Horner's in 1995 and installed 24 hour security guards. My friend Sylvia told me she feels safer.
通常当你听说那些项目区时，你会听说情况很糟糕，而且正在恶化。但当我去霍纳时，我听到了一个不同的故事。那里仍然有枪击、毒品和团伙。但是，大多数人告诉我，情况已经放缓了。1991年，亨利·霍纳的居民对市政府提起了诉讼并赢了。因此，芝加哥住房管理局正在清理它，翻新旧公寓，安装新电梯，拆除最坏的建筑。他们在1995年将233个家庭搬出了霍纳，并安装了24小时保安。我的朋友西尔维娅（Sylvia）告诉我，她觉得更安全了。
So it's doing a lots better since 20 years it was looking around here, so. Crime [UNINTELLIGIBLE] a lot better too. They ain't doing too much shooting or nothing, so that's good. Police are around a little more, so that's better too. Since they put that United Center up there, because they  watch that a lot.
所以比起20年前这附近的样子，它好多了，所以。犯罪[无法辨认]也好了很多。他们没怎么开枪什么的，所以那很好。警察在这附近多了一点，所以那也更好。自从他们在那儿盖了那个联合中心，因为他们经常看着那儿。
Sylvia says police are always driving around the neighborhood since the United Center was built. I visited my grandmother, and she said the same thing. That things are getting better. We sat in her apartment with gospel music on the radio and a preacher on the television. And she told me about life in Horner now.
西尔维娅说自从联合中心建成后，警察总是在社区周围巡逻。我拜访了我的祖母，她也说了同样的话。情况正在好转。我们坐在她的公寓里，听着收音机里的福音音乐，电视上放着牧师的节目。她告诉了我现在在霍纳的生活。
Well, it's not too bad around here. I never read about nothing happening around here, like somebody getting killed in a drive-by shooting. It's not too bad. I walk out this house every day and goes off. Lights be out, I have to take a flashlight, but I'm not afraid. I'm not afraid. Of course, I got God, first of all.
嗯，这附近不太糟。我从来没读到过这附近发生什么事，比如有人在得来速枪击中丧生。不太糟。我每天走出这个屋子，然后出去。灯灭了，我得带手电筒，但我并不害怕。我不害怕。当然，首先，我有上帝。
One of the things that the President and the delegates at the convention won't see when they look at Horner from across the United Center parking lot, is The Boys & Girls Club. Physically The Boys & Girls Club hasn't changed since I was little. Old pool tables, a basketball court, cinderblock wall, it's not in great shape. I talked to the grandfather of the community, Major Adam.
总统和大会代表从联合中心停车场对面看霍纳时，他们看不到的一件事是男孩女孩俱乐部（The Boys & Girls Club）。从物理上讲，男孩女孩俱乐部从我小时候起就没变过。旧台球桌、篮球场、煤渣砖墙，状况不是很好。我采访了社区的祖父，亚当少校（Major Adam）。
He's worked at the Boys & Girls Club for 40 years. Everybody knows him, and everybody respects him. Kids would listen to Major before they'd listen to teacher, or parents, or even a police. He's the only person at Horner who can walk into the middle of a gang fight and make it stop. In fact, he's famous for jumping into the middle of fights. And Major would be the first person to tell you about all the fights he's stopped.
他在男孩女孩俱乐部工作了40年。每个人都知道他，每个人都尊重他。孩子们在听老师、家长甚至警察之前，会先听少校的。他是霍纳唯一一个能走进团伙火拼中间并让它停止的人。事实上，他以跳进战斗中而闻名。少校会是第一个告诉你他制止了多少战斗的人。
He's going to jump on eight guys with these three knives. I didn't know he had three knives. But he had one in his hand he was going to get these guys. So I had to grab this guy and take this knife away from him. While the guy came out there, 12 of them was jumping on one guy. And it made me so mad, I said, well look, I'm going to take all 12 of you guys, one at a time. And I'd take them one at a time, and I whooped all 12 of them. I'm gonna do do it by myself. I picked them up and throwed them over the fence. I'm telling you, you got--
他要用这三把刀跳向八个人。我不知道他有三把刀。但他手里有一把，他要干掉这些人。所以我不得不抓住这家伙并从他手中夺走这把刀。当那家伙出来时，他们中有12个人正围攻一个人。我火冒三丈，我说，好吧，听着，我要干掉你们12个，一次一个。我一次一个，我打败了他们12个。我要自己搞定。我把他们提起来扔过栅栏。我告诉你，你必须——
Some people say the neighborhood is safer because over 200 families moved out. There are fewer people to get in trouble or shoot each other. My friend Sylvia says, people have less time to fool around, because the Housing Authority is hiring residents to do construction and clean the place up. Another friend of mine says, people are getting their acts together, because now the city is kicking people out and tearing buildings down, and they don't want to lose their homes. But the way Major sees it, the neighborhood is better, because there are people in Horner who are trying to make a difference.
有些人说社区更安全了，因为200多个家庭搬走了。惹麻烦或互相射击的人少了。我的朋友西尔维娅说，人们没有时间瞎混，因为住房管理局雇佣居民进行施工和清理工作。我的另一个朋友说，人们正变得正经起来，因为现在城市在赶人走、拆楼，他们不想失去家园。但按照少校的看法，社区变好了，因为在霍纳有些人正试图带来改变。
I'll tell you, crime have went down in our neighborhood, this neighborhood, because you have a guy like me working in the neighborhood. When you walk in there, a lot of them gang bangers just came, I sent them. So is a lot of things I do for them. I let them play basketball. When they want to go back to school, I see that they go back to school. They go to jail, I send them money and stuff like that.
我告诉你，犯罪在我们的社区，这个社区，下降了，因为有个像我这样的人在社区工作。当你走进去时，很多混混都来了，我遣送了他们。所以我为他们做了很多事。我让他们打篮球。当他们想回学校时，我确保他们回学校。他们进监狱，我给他们寄钱之类的事。
Like my Aunt Millie says, you can't beautify the outside, when the inside ain't right. Major's working hard to beautify the inside.
就像我的米莉阿姨（Aunt Millie）说的，当里面不好时，你不能美化外面。少校正努力美化里面。
In the main room at The Boys & Girls Club, there's a trophy case. Inside there are all the trophies won by Horner baseball teams, basketball teams, and football teams. And pinned to the back of the trophy case, there are pictures of Horner residents who've made something of their lives, who've gotten out of the project, went on to do great things.
在男孩女孩俱乐部的主厅里，有一个奖杯陈列柜。里面放着霍纳棒球队、篮球队和橄榄球队赢得的所有奖杯。奖杯柜背面贴着霍纳居民的照片，他们成就了自己的生活，走出了项目区，去做了伟大的事情。
All three of those young men up t there are teachers. They grew up in the area.
在那上面的那三个年轻人都是老师。他们是在这个地区长大的。
All three of them?
他们三个都是？
Yeah, all three there. And this is Dr. Steven Parker at Chicago State. That's Verdine from Earth, Wind & Fire.
是的，那三个都是。这是芝加哥州立大学的史蒂文·帕克（Steven Parker）博士。那是“地球、风与火”乐队（Earth, Wind & Fire）的维丁（Verdine）。
Then he pointed out a blank spot, and asked me for a picture. His way of saying, he knew I was going to make it.
然后他指着一个空白处，向我要一张照片。他用这种方式表示，他知道我会成功的。
Well, This American Life is produced by Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, Julie Snyder, Nancy Updike, and me. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margie Rochlin, Alix Spiegel and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Starlee Kine. Some work in todays show was produced by Peter Clowney and Alix Spiegel. Musical help today from John Connors, Steve Cushing, and Anaheed Alani.
嗯，《美国生活》由亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、布鲁·切维尼（Blue Chevigny）、朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）、南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我制作。特约编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margie Rochlin）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和斯塔莉·基恩（Starlee Kine）提供制作帮助。今天节目中的一些工作由彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowney）和阿利克斯·斯皮格尔制作。今天来自约翰·康纳斯（John Connors）、史蒂夫·库欣（Steve Cushing）和阿纳希德·阿拉尼（Anaheed Alani）的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. two Well, you know you can listen to most of our programs for absolutely free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs our site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买这个或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。嗯，你知道你可以在互联网上的网站www.thislife.org免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢管理我们网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who is worrying about the effects of this radio show.
WBEZ管理层由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）监督，他正在担心这个广播节目的影响。
It's very harmful. And it's like a yodel out to the immigrants.
它非常有害。就像对着移民喊麦。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week for more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来收听更多《美国生活》的故事。
It's saying, are you out there? Is there anyone out there? Would you like to come to America?
它在说，你们在那儿吗？有人在那儿吗？你想来美国吗？
PRI Public Radio International.
PRI国际公共广播电台。